on the mound for the padres after a
fantastic august is blake snow 28 year
old making his 26th start he has allowed
three earned runs or fewer in nine of
his last 11 appearances one out here in
the first inning luis surrender
2-2 swinging a miss got him with the
slider down maybe the curve ball either
way a strikeout and two down at the top
of the first inning two down here in the
first inning for phil gosling and a
swing and a miss gets away briefly from
nola so he's got to throw him out and he
does [ __ ] nuns gonna have to throw
strikes as he did by the way wednesday
night against the yankees he walked only
two in his three and two third innings
but was handed a four to one defeat well
now one on
jake batts for the first time there's a
swing and a miss at a good change up
right there and down on strikes goes
cronenworth
1-0 pitch a little chopper hit out
towards second stop there by fletcher he
will throw out fam and the ending ends
on a 4-3 roundout
in the second and here's kurt suzuki
one and two here it is suzuki swings and
misses at a pitch in the dirt picked up
by nola he will tag him out and another
one two three inning for blake snell he
caps this one with a k walk in a single
after a ground out brings up hassan kim
first things first here's the 2-2 home
to kim
got him with a heater tripled up on
fastballs in so two on two out now
got him with a fastball
and not and indeed in and out of trouble
brendan marsh
lead it off here's another one slider
swing and a miss and he strikes him out
strikeout number four for blake snell
out number one of the third inning
snellzilla with the slider one down in
the third for packy naughton the pitcher
batting out of the eight spot swinging a
miss here
back-to-back strikeouts in fact three in
a row for snell he's got five k's on the
night two down
fly ball
right center field fernando moving over
and under will make the catch it's one
two three third for estelle stelzilla we
go to the bottom of the third inning no
score from petco park packy naughton
gets ready to face the top of the
batting order
a rocket to third gobbled up by mayfield
hardest hit ball tonight by a padre and
it goes down as the first down here in
the third inning two balls and no
strikes to count to fam
that's into shallow center field for
marsh to wrap off the side
blake snell starts his fourth inning of
work
david fletcher skies one to right and in
to make the catches myers one pitch one
out of the fourth inning that'll work
love him swinging early in the easy fly
balls one out and that'll bring up luis
ranjifo
rick snell has retired the first ten
angels he has faced in the game swinging
a miss rahifo strikes out that's six
strikeouts for snell two down
half does it in the k column and this
one he gets them with the slider phil
gosling here's the pitch and it is taken
right down the middle at the knees
strike three called back to back case
for snell in another one two three
inning 12 in a row set down to start the
game for blake's only been four base
runners in the game all four of them
have come on this side of the scorecard
unfortunately will myers leads things
off
myers sends a ball to left
room for adele
that's the loudest out of the game so
far one away
and then some time in oakland
off the mound to feel this position yeah
and a bad toss and he still makes the
play two quick outs now for austin nola
nola singled in the second
and he lines out here in the fourth
madrid's have the only two hits of the
game and jack mayfield about to lead it
off here for the angels swinging a miss
and he strikes out mayfield that's eight
games for snell one down off the table
with the yakker
adele to left fam moving in will make
the catch whoa
suzuki out in front of the curve pops it
up to left field fam over towards the
line striding underneath of it he'll get
there and make a two-handed catch a
fifth straight one two three inning for
blake snell to start his night
absolutely brilliant hassan kim will
lead things off for san diego in the
bottom of the fifth
a called strike three taken by kim
yeah that's in the lower part of the
strike so no doubt that's a strike
and he strikes out snell that's five for
[ __ ] tonight
tati sends it back up the middle fletch
is right there behind the bag to make
for a breezy one two three fifth for
pacquiao head to the sixth and brandon
marsh is going to lead it off here 12
consecutive hitless inning record is 12
and a third bill laxton in 74.
[Applause]
strike recall nine strikeouts for snell
keen wong will indeed pinch it for
naughton
swing and a miss in a pitch in the dirt
nolan's gonna throw him out and he does
ten strikeouts for snell two down in the
sixth inning two down in the sixth juan
lagaris
1-1 is a fly ball to center field tatis
with room
stelzilla is perfect through six tonight
san diego here's jake cronin worth now
he struck out and singled against
naughton
bronenworth lines it right to goslin
the halos turned that into a double play
blake snell
starts his seventh inning of work he has
struck out 10.
stay tuned we got a good one going
downtown right now that is ball four and
the first base runner to reach is david
fletcher
drops it down well played snell's got to
get over
he won't
beat it out snell reached out trying to
tag him and the padres are going to
challenge snell thought he got him on
the tag
he realizes he's not going to get to the
bag so he tags him got him yeah
he's out alfonso marquez
does indeed overturn it one out runner
at third and goslin
gosling strikes out making 11 for blake
snell two down in the seventh inning
with fletcher at third feel at first and
joe adele will be next here for the
angel
swings and lines a base hit out of the
reach of cronenworth that's going to
score one that's going to score two and
joe adele breaks the no hitter and the
angels have a two-nothing lead
with one out of the base is empty
picks on the first pitch bounces it up
the middle kim tried some razzle dazzle
but ohtani's aboard on an infield single
swing and a mess and stamens able to
strike out fletcher at the inning two
outs top of the order fernando tatis
junior 043
here's the 0-1 and this is
skyed in the air to shallow center marsh
is under he'll make the catch on that
one and that is how the inning ends good
as blake snell was tonight it's the
angels with a two-nothing lead luis
renjifo leads things off red heapho
on top of petco porch solo shot three
nothing halos
is extremely strong when he gets a
fastball in the inner half especially
hitting from the left side down in a
little more difficult for slider but
who's ready to jump halo fans loving
this
at petco park luis randhipo
[Applause]
next pitch he chops this one over the
mound it's stopped by the second baseman
only one chance for an out though is
coming in and scoring is gosling and
adele will be thrown out
he'll get an rbi on that 4-3 ground out
and the angels get their second run in
the inning and now lead it four to
nothing raiser down to the final out
jericho far represents the last chance
for san diego
bro far sends a fly ball out to center
field can of corn stop for brandon marsh
and the angels combine
on a three-hit shutout
[Applause]